but if i'm getting any shades of like fu
snyder person in this after matrix
resurrections
just like the drama of wb
is so weird to me because it's so front
and center with their films now yeah you
got crimes of grindelwald or whatever
that followed was that what's that
what's that the secrets of dumb
dumbledore yeah you have the secrets of
dumbledore the matrix resurrections were
so apparent with their crap and now you
got the flash movie and the snider
versus like every movie studio every
film pretty much has drama that we just
don't hear about it's so freaking common
but it really seems like with warner
brothers their films are having so much
bad press as a part of their movies that
are coming out and the only film i'm
comfortable to say i'm looking forward
to out of warner brothers is the god
batman
does that exist
with any of this
[Music]
greetings and salutations ladies and
gentlemen we are here today to talk
about what twitter has been loving
talking about over the weekend what a
way to kick off the new year so many
positive things
everyone's getting their wish well if
the flash movie didn't have enough
problems getting started it's creating
more problems as it's already almost
done in case you haven't heard many
scoopers have been reporting on this
this really took off after grace
randolph put out a tweet about it she
even went trending but there's been a
lot of scoopers who have backed this
report up basically the the headline of
it all is the flash movie to erase
superman bat fleck and the snyder versus
in total is how it's all gonna go but we
got a lot of information to climb
through here as people who are big fans
of the snyder cut one of the best things
i've seen all year round as people have
been championing
restored the snyder verse we definitely
got some opinions we want to go through
all the facts so we want to go through
what grace randolph said what andy
muschietti said what ezra miller said
and then of course some plot points that
were leaked as well about this so we're
going to quickly dish out all the
information because all that information
is very important to this conversation
of course give our opinions afterwards
here's a spoiler warning because it
sounds like a lot of this is true okay
so let's kick off with grace randolph
the first thing she said as i've told
you with update the flash bafflex final
appearance old footage of cavil used on
tv new justice league formed supergirl
is new superman keaden working with
black canary picks batgirl's new batman
this is new dc let's be open-minded and
give it a fair shot you can already hear
the woke police oh yeah the keaton black
canary batgirl stuff obviously happens
in her movie to clarify now like i said
many people have already backed this
claim uh folks like my time to shine
hello and many accurate leaks regarding
spider-man no way home even put this
tweet out i don't usually tweet about dc
stuff but i happy a friend who have seen
the flash and the movie will erase every
movie snyder has done man of steel
batman v suit just hurts to read man
maybe superman and justice league never
happened now erased from continuity
affleck and cavill are both gone now in
regards to what andy muschietti the
director had to say this movie is a bit
of a hinge in the sense that he presents
this stuff for exactly what he said
spanish spanish i forgot what he is
he's italian now
that implies a unified universe for all
the cinematic iterations that we've seen
before are valid mushidi said it's
inclusive in the sense that it is saying
that all you've seen exists and
everything that you will see exists in
the same unified multiverse okay so it
sounds like it's not an entire erasure
it seems like it's just a license not to
have to acknowledge it anymore moving
forward yeah right still exists so we're
just not going to talk about it and then
of course ezra miller he was asked about
this who has actually been involved in
the creative process for this movie he
was also cast by zack snyder originally
and uh someone asked him on his
instagram i believe fans are going crazy
thinking this movie is a race in zack's
movies they don't see the potential this
movie will bring then ezra said as he
was choking someone no power or force in
any known megaverse water could ever
erase zack snyder's mighty works you can
take that quote
take that to the bank to the press to
the school to the military and the other
pillar of capitalism i'm forgetting
because of that thing where if you try
to think of a group of things you always
forget what are them classic miller
answers miller answered like an answer
without an answer yeah really no that's
that's the stage of marketing it's all
about the non-answering yeah he spent
most of that talking about how you could
take this quote and then made a bunch of
references to
pillars of capitalism you're not gonna
wanna take because it's gonna be a
nightmare to make it make sense okay so
the question is does this or does this
not erase the snyder verse and from what
i can gather a little bit of both yes
and no what flashlight news said on
twitter was some fans have taken this as
debunking yesterday's reports and that
wasn't our intent the rumors are true
and i really trust flash film news
they've probably been the most reliable
when it comes to any they're called
flash film news for a reason and they
it's their job to be as reliable as
possible when it comes to this stuff
we'll establish a new dce universe
however this new continuity will
preserve the world that snyder built
what i'm trying to understand here
because then paul from heavy spoilers
the greatest fraud in the world said
sounds like it's basically going to be a
crisis on infinite earth's flashpoint
new 52 situation where some stuff is
dropped whilst other elements are kept
to form a new kind of dc eu and i think
that is the most optimistic summary you
can have about this situation yeah i
feel like that's kind of what comes in
part and parcel with these multiverses
is that opportunity to go what work that
people definitely want to see kept and
then what can we you know fix snyder
verse in particular is a fandom and and
the movies as a whole the praise and
love and adoration for them seems to
have grown over time
i think right away for a lot of people
it wasn't an instant like for them yeah
you know
myself included especially when it came
to bvs in particular i mean you guys
know how we feel about it by that point
for me personally i think like allowing
batfleck to move on that makes sense
because ben affleck just worries me as a
human being
yeah he does not look alright it seems
like he can very emotionally be
triggered and i just want him to be okay
and he's made it pretty clear that he
does not want to continue on and
franchise properties you know what i
mean with that in mind like the way he's
talked about the flash it seemed like
yeah i just want to move on and and this
was my way of saying bye to batman
officially like let's just make it clear
this is me saying bye the part that that
seems like the the most upsetting
is um superman being removed
like we've all i feel a lot of us have
been wanting that follow-up to man of
steel it seems like he's earned it and
it doesn't sound like they're gonna give
henry cavill a chance to even say bye
based off of everything that's been
being reported on early they're at least
giving ben affleck a chance to say bye
but it doesn't even sign that they're
giving henry cavill a chance to say
goodbye you never know that shazam 2
cameo could still happen yeah you never
know man that's the send-off we'd want
and then with henry cavill's like
popularity really growing as of late not
just in regards to the snide reverse
phantom but like the work that he's been
doing on witcher i think it would be
really
silly
it's really silly it's quite upsetting
the idea of especially him
being the one to be removed my faith in
the i and warner brothers restoring the
snyder verse has slowly gone down over
the months it's gone to the point where
i'm like i just i don't believe it's
gonna happen i will of course support
the possibility of it happening if it
ever goes trending i'm of course
retweeting it if you ask me do i want it
to happen absolutely do i believe warner
brothers is gonna give in and do it i
know i don't
they want to get as far away from that
as they can right so the dc fandom
funny enough that's a that's their
little event it's created quite a divide
you know like there are people like us
who are in this weird dichotomy snyder
verse all the way and i was excited for
this flash movie and i'm still very
intrigued to find out how this all plays
out i really want to know what's going
to happen how are they going to execute
this can they execute this in a way like
i know there's going to be fans right
away of the snyder verse who are
instantly going to write this off not
not be open-minded even if they try to
be they just won't be able to be there's
going to be those people out there
there's going to be people like us who
are like let's just find out let's let's
see maybe we can get on maybe it's good
i don't know maybe each time they roll
the dice some parts are good and some
parts are not so good so you never know
well it's funny because when you look at
what spider-man has done spoilers for
spider-man no way home sort of when you
look at what they've done a big part of
what's been great about how they brought
back a couple of people it's allowed for
a semblance of closure but it's also
kind of reflective of what happened with
the snyder fan base and how they want
another andrew garfield the movie to
happen because like you give them
something now they want more right
and at least the air cut and hey i'm
part of that too i want the air cut i
want the amazing spider-man 3 and i want
the nervous starting sniper what i think
though what marvel has done is they've
done a great job at establishing
multiverse to the point where it's like
well i couldn't totally see how we can
keep the tom hall and franchise alive
and do an andrew garfield one and i
think they're a prime example of how we
can have that co-exist and you think
that with doing this multiverse flash
movie that they can create a scenario
where both can exist and not feel like
hey um
this timeline is not a race but we're
definitely not diving into it ever again
again despite the fact that there are a
lot of you who really want that to
continue and despite the fact that we're
building this new arm on parts of that
old one yeah that are going to
automatically remind the people who were
there for that of those movies it's like
we're always gonna have that feeling of
something is not complete something is
incomplete and it seems like there's
gonna just be this constant stain in the
dc universe that we won't able to be
true be able to truly move past for such
a long time
yeah and this solution also to me feels
very similar to what they tried to do
with justice league where it's like oh
marvel's having all this success with
the multiverse and yes this flash movie
has been in the works for a little while
they've you know obviously caught on to
the multiverse stories in the zeitgeist
but it feels like another attempt to
basically catch up without actually
doing the foundational work and you know
like all new characters leading the
justice league aside it seems like this
is another sort of finicky move from the
warner brothers dc camp it doesn't feel
like a confident new direction based on
some mistakes made before it feels like
uh we got to rework this and uh
multiverses are in so we can use that as
our our in to getting what we want but
it doesn't sound very finessed at the
moment at the moment it doesn't i mean
that's what i'm saying like we'll see
just gotta watch it and then judge it
afterwards but it's unfortunate because
he got this new lineup of a justice
league that's supposed to be formed now
david f samberg he's been out there
being like i actually haven't heard
anything about shazam being the new
justice league the idea it sounds like
is that the new batgirl is supposed to
be the replacement for the new batman
and like like michael keaton's going to
hand off the baton to her
and then that makes me go why are you
debuting her solo
i don't remember it's a show or movie
now but why are you developing debuting
her on hbo max justice league is cinema
you should be more confident and it's
like a lot of people go because you're
trying to drive users to the service i
get that but especially with the hbo
maxes it just feels like a downgrade
yeah
debut this massive character who's
supposed to be the replacement for
batman on this small screen well yeah
that feels like another ploy to get
people to sign up because i don't know
that's the biggest thing we hear about
these days ah disney didn't get the
numbers they want uh hbo you get the
numbers they want and what you know
generates the content is subscriptions
and then you have also with the new
super girl and it just seems like
they're not being allowed at the the
proper opportunity to be introduced to
form the new justice league there's
already so much baggage happening and
already so much criticism going their
way that i don't feel like they're going
to be given a fair shot to be introduced
as the new justice league yeah you know
what i mean and i feel like that's just
unfair
to them as actors and characters can't
cast an uphill battle for sure yeah
especially in light of the public
defense and outcry and everything
surrounding the snyder verse and it's
not even feeling like much of a
flash-focused movie at this point which
is the weirdest part no it's not even
the trailer felt like a flash focus it
feels like a big apparatus to get their
universe back on track that happens to
feature the flash prominently as always
i say wait to find out however where do
i stand now with this it sounds like
[ __ ] it's like skeptical for sure and
what really sucks about all this is that
when we say snyder verse it's not only
encompassing erasing bvs man of steel
and events of wonder woman it sounds
like too i believe it's also supposed to
be erasing the events of suicide squad
david ayers i i can kind of understand
even though i want the haircut which i'm
sure would be a very different response
for me but james gunn's the suicide
squad i thought was brilliant and the
fact of how much they've also been like
james gunn yeah we're going to be
working with him more in the future like
how does james gunn feel about this yeah
how does margot robbie feel about this
and she's been such a staple for the dc
eu as well to one of their most
successful parts she's yeah her
character alone and her interpretation
has been instantly iconic are you
erasing her now like what what exactly
is this gonna so it's yeah they'll be
keeping some and not keeping others
because it's like it's the whole thing
when you rewrite a timeline as other
things can be kept while others are
messed with i get that they have another
aquaman movie coming out so they got to
have some idea of what they're doing
yeah i don't know i'm open-minded there
are things i'm absolutely looking
forward to with this film i i like the
teaser trailer did excite me and i
there's no bullshitting that the teaser
trailer excited the hell out of me i'm
excited to see michael keaton again but
if i'm getting any shades of like f u
snyder person in this after matrix
resurrections
just like that the drama of wb
is so weird to me because it's so front
and center with their films now yeah you
got crimes of grindelwald or whatever
that follow was that what's that what's
that the secrets of dumb dumbledore yeah
you have the secrets of dumbledore the
matrix resurrections was so apparent
with their crap and now you got the
flash movie and the cider versus like
every movie studio every film pretty
much has drama that we just don't hear
about it's so freaking common but it
really seems like with warner brothers
their films are having so much bad press
as a part of their movies that are
coming out and the only film i'm
comfortable to say i'm looking forward
to out of warner brothers is the goddamn
batman
yeah i mean i'm sure they do but matt
reeves is just such a confident and
assured filmmaker and i think yeah that
movie just has the look existing in a
pocket yeah unless you're a
solo batman property it's gonna be
choppy water because i think they're
just not good at putting out a
version or a vision of these movies
their plan that actually feels like a
confident plan a race is probably not
the right word you know just just
re-write shoving it over there to
collect dust forever yeah refueling
until 10 years from now some filmmaker
comes out of the woodwork and goes we're
going to bring back the cider version
now we're going to make a sequel
directly to zack snyder's justice yeah
ignore all these other installments all
right guys what do you think about this
news had a lot of thoughts about this
you know we're pretty late to it but
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button we
will catch you guys soon
you